okay let's stick with the phones Pat
enjoyed that one I can tell let's go to
the phones a 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 let's go
to our caller from the 404 area code
who's this Jeff what's going on how much
I'm glad I'm the latter the next guy you
took on the pole because that guy and
that's the definition of someone who's
completely and informed you asked me for
a specific question about a specific
policy and he can't give you one
specific right it's very sad very sad
but I Bible thank you for taking my call
I love your show I'm a recent viewer
following you through YouTube and glad
you take calls but I'm one of those
leftists who is not really believing the
Trump Russia election collusion story
okay I find it to be a red herring to
avoid talking about really the drilled
neoliberal problems of the Democrats
there's a constantly go ahead I'm sorry
so which aspect of it don't you believe
um well I thought you believed Trump had
ties with Russia as far as money long
money laundering goes okay he's been
dealing with Russian banks forever but
as far as election interference and
collusion to interfere I don't see that
as something that I think Israel does
more to infect our our elections and
then Russia has okay but hold on stake
out he's by peace if we can Jeff so just
so we can figure out exactly how you've
sort of put together this belief you're
saying you don't believe that there were
Russian attempts to interfere and that
you believe that that's actually
something that's being used to cover up
the fact that there's neo liberals in
the Democratic Party intelligence
agencies mostly run by Republicans or
historically Republicans came up with
the assessment that Russia did interfere
so what does that have to do with
Democrats in Leo Leo liberals do you
just not trust what all agents agencies
well to begin with the initial
assessment by the three agencies was
they had moderate to high confidence
right that rush to man that's not
evidence
and ever since that moment people have
trumped out things like for example the
the CNN bust in September of a couple
weeks ago about the email there was a
huge pool about it the three team in
this guy Jeff I'm sorry Doug was the
last guy I'm still having PTSD from him
so look Jeff let me let me just before
we get off on to CNN emails so you're
saying that first you said you think
that the Russia stuff is something that
Democrats are using to distract from the
fact that they are neoliberals but now
you're saying it's actually the
intelligence agencies that you don't
think are really trustworthy so what
does that have to do with the Democrats
well I think that as far as mainstream
Democrats they are refusing to
acknowledge the fact that it wasn't
Russia in their fearing sand the elect
lost that vote for them hello oh boy
Jeff you're breaking up we were really
getting into the meat of it there but
now Jeff's gone I I was going to next
get to know what would change your mind
right because he seems to give giving
different reasons why he doesn't believe
it aren't necessarily all connected but
I like Jeff Jeff's a great guy
absolutely great guy